you
thanks very much yeah I'm a work at
mediamath here I work on the creatives
team i'm i'm actually a manager here and
i have two opening slots for scala devs
i'll just put that out there we do the
ad serving so lots of requests a second
fun stuff good challenges all right auto
lifts automatic type drive lifting wow
it sounds pretty fancy and cool this
this actually came about or this this
whole library happened that talk that he
gave last year here I actually went
around the country started given that
talk and over in Boston Eugene the guy
that writes SBT he stopped me at one of
it one of the slides and he was like you
know like I really don't care about the
rest of this but that's cool and you put
that in a library and what he didn't
know is that prior to you know the talks
Embling it up and getting a slides ready
to go I had actually experimented around
with a lot of things like that one slide
so I took those ideas and I started
putting it into this library and as I
started like getting these things in I
got really excited because I thought it
was I thought it was onto something I
and I think this is really cool and it's
it's finally at the point where i can i
can share it and open it up and let you
guys see but before we begin up
housewive lifting well lifting what is
it you know you hear that and you're
like yeah you lift bro yeah but what
lifting is is it's actually it's a
really simple concept that they've given
this weird term to like they always do
in functional programming which it
really doesn't need to a fit if it was
what it was people would know it
immediately so let's say we have some
function like a really easy function you
were just growing integers here we're
taking something that has a signature of
intent and let's suppose we have an
object well there's a list of in
teachers this is great this has a
signature of list int and if we try and
naively use these two together we're
going to give a pile time error because
scholars going to say like this is a
list of ink this function works on no
intervent what are you doing ah none of
us actually would do this we grab list
and we'd say dot map square because
that's that's what you do that's that's
kind of what map is is for and so
lifting if you think about it it's it's
where we have a function and we sort of
invert this and we say like okay you
make my list the argument so we take we
take something in essence if you look at
this you sort of squint in and take a
step back that has a signature of intent
and we lift it into our yeah there's
something wrong with my mic go for it
how's that yes I put in my pocket if it
starts like it just moves a lot all
right I'll try and keep sorry so all
right lifting we have this function into
int and we want to lift it into this
this higher higher kinda context we want
to lift it into two lists so now we
actually come out with a function called
you know which has a signature of list
event to list event by using this this
function that had intent and and we can
do this easily with a list because it
has this map function but this map
function if you think about it lots of
other things have map you know options
have maps sets have maps that's because
these things are all something called a
funk door they're actually more than
just that but we can generalize this
concept and we can say as long as in
Scala there exists a funk tour for the
type i'm trying to work on i can lift it
up taking this function so I might write
this lift function like I have up there
and I just call it like this lift list
lift list square and if you don't know
what a functor is it's again a very very
hand wavy it's just something that has a
map I mean that's it and if you've never
seen functor if you never like seen
scholars adore cats or you know one of
those various types that FN map f we had
lists up there and f it's actually just
underneath the hood delegating tube map
is that what lool is different now
that's because my highlighting is not
the best so yeah I should have probably
fig fixed that all right so that's
really cool it's a nice neat little
abstraction so why would we why do we
want to lift I mean why not just just
you
math I mean it's simple it's there it's
basic it's it's fairly straightforward
up even works when we have like weird
nested types i mean that's that's
readable right you can you can see
what's going on it's nice got nice and
denting and things like that as your
type start getting more complicated as
you start stacking them up i'm going to
start having to use a lot more maps and
if you don't include on these maps
generally you're okay because the
compiler will come back and say like no
you missed one you goof door you went a
little too far but it does start getting
gnarly I mean I've put this on to one
line so we could be like Oh easy one two
three but most you guys would start
indenting or to look kind of like a set
of staircases or or sideways pyramid or
something like that we'd start having
the same issues or same complaints that
you often see when people write jquery
code you know keeps keep sort of moving
off to the side and you kind of have to
slide your screen over to see what's
going on so that's that's not very cool
and then then you deal with something
like this and you I give up you know how
many of you guys have actually like
actually write code like that with a
tight that's so so deeply just one
person okay a couple more so we got we
got a bunch more people awesome cool for
those that don't why not this is this
just it's scary right this is like a
real pain and he has to deal with right
but look at what this set mean let's
take a second and actually see what this
would would say just looking at the
types of this for an API call the first
thing is the future you know this is
saying okay this isn't a synchronous
call I'm going to get this you know at
some point great API should be a
synchronous awesome good deal we have
option that says like something may not
be there so maybe you're looking at
account / the ID / you know purchases
and you've got some sort of form field
that goes in so option would tell you
does that account exists or not
validation you've never seen it it's
it's kind of like try only you can
accumulate the error so if you have like
three fields in your form that are
invalid you can actually hand back to
the user going these three forms are
wrong rather than the user changing one
form and getting a thing back going like
now you you messed this one too like
that's just user friendly and this is
the thing that we want if I didn't do
this if I tried to avoid this stuff and
avoid like the compiler coming back and
like making me explicitly check and
handle each of these cases I might just
do a future of list but now you know
list of you know an ill that that can be
both that the account doesn't exist or
that there are no like purchase records
or something like that and if I had an
incorrect form I might stick it as
exceptions in the future and then far
away from the call site I have to
remember and I have to keep in my head
this mental track of the different
errors and exceptions and then try and
handle them from memory essentially or
you know write some unit tests to have
it all these things that the compiler
itself could do for us but this is a
real pain to deal with I mean let's
let's you know not not kid ourselves
yeah yeah here we go so this is what it
might look like with lifting and we're
being a lot more explicit what's
happening here I mean we're actually
forming this ladder that we can walk up
and climb here we have lists and
validation an option future these things
are composing together and now he has a
function that isn't just into int its
future option validation list int to
future option validation list gin and
then you know really yeah really it's
just like that it's simple its basic and
clear up but I just want to I just want
to sort of let's play a mental game here
or let's let's do a thought argument if
you will so push button solutions
everybody likes push button solutions so
you're on the 46th floor of the building
right this is this is where you came
this is
where we are how'd you get here you you
took the elevator right so when we think
about you know things that we have or
things that we interact with and the
world which would we rather do or which
would we rather have that we want to
have things that are easy to use or
things that were easy for some other
person to make and I think the answer is
easy to use and i'll even I'm going to
go a step further and try and prove it
stairs stairs are really easy from an
engineering perspective I mean they've
existed from the dawn of time probably
like there's this wall that's really
high if I build it any higher I won't be
able to see what's going on I should
probably fix something so we make stairs
we take a board and we place it here and
we place the next board up and a little
bit further and it's easy to use a
self-explanatory you just just walk up
it but it's a very manual process and
manual sucks elevators on the other hand
they're easy right except if you're
going to make them think about it this
you're going to take a metal box you're
going to take it from ground floor and
going to move it up like 500 feet and
it's got to go up and down so you have
to put an engine in there and some sort
of pulley system and you you have to
have emergency brakes in case the pulley
system fails or you you actually the
biggest challenge I think is electricity
I mean no one's going to get in a box
thats dark and go up 500 feet right
that's no no one would trust that so
getting electricity into a box that can
go I mean this building is actually 72
floor so up and down 700 feet that's
that's actually pretty I'd like to know
how they do it because i don't i don't
really know so when you got in and you
walk through the gates and got through
security did you go up to the elevators
and go like wow those things are really
complex I'm taking the stairs no yeah
you push the button you walked in it was
no someone did it for you while it's
even better you didn't have to push
anything well it's got a really nice
interface but
so you ignored all all this complexity
and that sort of thing and if you're and
if you're building something I mean
think about the converse who's going to
build a seventy two story building with
just stares I mean who's going to rent
the 72nd floor nobody so we look at
these things and we talk about this
stuff where I just show lifting is cool
it's concise it's nice it's really
beautiful but we still have to do it
ourselves I'd actually have to write
that in my code and that's that's kind
of the problem that all of this is going
to solve I'm going to do that for you so
I'm going to have this nasty future
option validation list int this yeah
crazy thing and i'm just going to do dot
lift map square and if you've never seen
scala test the one ready strips away the
future and out i get exactly what I've
done and maybe I had in an option
success list of one two three now I've
got out my some success list 149 and it
just works I get the right values I get
the right types but more than just that
more than just forcing us down like into
it into just using the int this thing is
going to be typed driven much like the
buttons on the elevator that you press
to say which floor you give the
signature of the function to the
compiler and it says i need to lift it
this far up so it does that for you so
now future list option int i pass in an
option int now i'm going to get out of
future list int and i'll just work or
maybe i passed in a nun i got out of 0
flat map because if you got map why not
flat map too so this works as a matter
of fact a whole bunch of functions i put
in there should be a lift map there a
whole bunch of functions that come in
and i'm just using an implicit class and
it works off of just a higher kind of
class and it provides you you know a lot
of things that you would see flat map
fold left fold right filter if you
haven't seen some of the other ones
don't don't worry about it but i've been
i've been
slightly coy because I didn't list the
return type there and here's where the
real magic happens so lift map is
actually defined such that if I know my
object is my F of a this higher kind of
type I pass in this function B to C and
then i will get an implicit and that
implicit will be specific to my the
object and my function and that weird
lift thought out that's a dependent type
so that that is a type parameter that is
explicit and defined to the type
parameters in that lift f but it's not
in any so that's why I can do like you
know lifting the option of int function
of that or a function of int and I still
get out the same type that is a
compile-time property at compile time it
will come out the compiler will do it
and it's built off of behind the scenes
some type level induction and I'm just
using that dependent type to pass out
the result of what it should be so
that's what it looks like under the hood
so let me let me flip over and trying
and you guys can interrupt me at any
point in time but let me show you a
little bit what this sort of looks like
can I make it bigger yeah what's that
yeah all right here we go awesome i'm
going to go over here and just seal some
stuff here
that's not what I wanted awesome so I've
just imported a whole bunch of things so
I've imported my auto lift and then I've
unpaired a whole bunch of scholars edge
underneath the hood notice however
everything that I showed you up to this
point in that library those implicit you
saw no scholar zet so if you guys don't
know what it is or don't want to use it
you actually won't see it in any of your
return types it's it's hidden in
underneath the hood that was another
goal of this library so let's do let me
just copy this now I've got this
function that returns a list option int
and I can take any of these so the first
guy here that we're going to oh that's
that's pretty shitty let's do this let's
let's do something else instead all
right 00 list dot lift map the first
thing I want to say is
is that any is not a type of that mat or
this this list but I'm still going to
i'm still going to be able to work with
this i'm still going to honor the fact
that you know functions are you know
contravariant and their their argument
covariant contravariant contravariant
and their arguments so they can they can
accept anything and we could take this
and I can I can use it in a bunch of
different cases here let me do it let me
do this and I can I can actually have
this function well I'll come up with a
quick
awesome cool I'm not going to get fancy
here so if I've got some list of bar of
a bar of one it will actually it will
work just fine but that two parameters
good eye so I'll just work that way too
it's great you can you can it's the same
thing as in this case map or as I
nesting grows it it will continue to to
follow suit and keep pace with you
preserving like the same kind of things
that we would expect out of any sort of
function whatsoever so up that's cool
and that's really great at the
object-oriented style like we have lists
and then we put methods on it or like
any sort of object that we have that
then has a method because we can get
some nice clean syntax in it it looks
good and that's all I'm wonderful but
skull also has this sort of like dual
quality where it's it's trying to be
both oo and FP it's trying to be like
two sides of the coin and so anytime you
have these like you know two sides of
the coin you get you get ideas from from
both sort of coming in and so what I
showed before was was this syntactic
extension to add these methods on to two
objects instead I'd actually like to
then show the other half the library
which is which is a bunch of lifting
context and to explain what these are a
little bit better let me talk about a
different language completely we're
going to talk functional programming
we're going to talk Haskell actually we
could talk lisp but let's talk Haskell
so lift them this actually exists in
Haskell if you've never written Haskell
or you can't read this does anybody know
not what's going on here this is just
again a higher-order function it takes
some function of A to B and it returns
again it lifted up into a monad but for
any sort of monad and this is slightly
different than what I had before which
you know i was using just functors even
though technically it's really not doing
anything more advanced so this list m
composes and composition in haskell like
that's a dot that's that's the
composition there so if I have a
function of A to B that's F and G is B
to C and I lift them this up I now have
an M of eight and be composed with an MB
to MC that's ma to MC well that's
equivalent to the other side and it also
composes with itself so I can do nested
compositions of this stuff and manually
come up with a bunch of liftings
manually that's actually kind of hard to
do in Scala though because we actually
have to be explicit about the the type
of the Monad because monads our type
class in high school and it's sort of
built into the language and scala where
we're sort of bodging it on using the
type class pattern we don't have real
type classes so lift them is cool but
there's a whole family of these guys
there's all the way up to like lift m5
so you can do things of more arity than
just this lift them to works on function
severity too and it's it's here where
the fact that we're using a monad sort
of comes out and we start doing things
so one of the one of the things about
lifting is or when you do it is when you
lift it up into this other context you
add a function you return to function so
you never lost the intrinsic properties
of the thing that you are lifting it
always retained the fact that this was a
function and now it's a function again
but you can also gain some things too so
in this case where we're mixing in like
we're lifting it into a monad ins we so
we can use the properties of a monad to
do some really nifty stuff so let's lift
them to this this edition with these two
lists 01 and and 12 is equivalent
to the function right below and if I
were to run this out and I look at the
command line I'd actually get out 1223 a
single list of 12 23 again using like
the fact that monads compose with
themselves only to get out just a single
list the same way I do here but again as
cool as that is any of this stuff that I
want to do with nested types I'd have to
manually do it so auto lifts the same
sort of deal as we did with the the
object-oriented approach I have a bunch
of a bunch of functions like this some
lifting context where I can pass in this
function this era t2 and it will work
the same way as it did before as a
matter of fact I can even start passing
in nested types and it will work the
same way with monadic composition to
come out with with the result that I
would expect so here's list option 0none
composed to the list option 3 well the
only thing I'm going to get out because
non-flat Maps something else is always
none is going to be this list option for
and like before I provide a whole bunch
of these contexts so 14 map flatmap
filter lift day that's where the plick
it is if you don't know what those are
never seen them don't worry about them
but they're there if you need them but
here I'm actually i'm using the object
oriented properties of scala because
getting these type classes sort of
workout is difficult and then trying to
get the end then and composing that that
kind of stuff like it would like such
still appear at least work in the same
manner of a function that I had before
so I I put these things in an object and
i added a map too because this actually
is it's essentially a functor and then
the way it works is actually that apply
method and if you look at it a little
bit you squinted a bit in this case I
know what my function is it's a to be in
this case the lifting is
these guys are working on the function
and now they can work on any type of
object they're given them or as opposed
to the other way the syntactic
extensions have an object and they can
work on any type of function that might
compile and they're both built upon this
same inductive proof the same like
lifteth that's coming in only only the
arguments are different or or slightly
different so there are some limitations
and I do have some future plans to this
library to try and try and address some
of these these limitations the first one
though is partial functions this is like
a chicken and an egg problem and I don't
know how to solve this so I don't think
I can I generally with your with your
like your map you know what the types
going to be it's quite explicit it's a
to be in this case even though you and I
can look at this and say like well
that's got to be a partial function on
list of any the compiler can't figure
that out it's got no context because the
implicit parameter that I'm going to
build depends upon the type of the
function but a partial function depends
upon that type information and chicken
and egg I don't know which one's coming
in which so I get this weird compile
error second thing is for comprehensions
that works because that's flat math and
map under the hood there's built-in
syntax into scholar the language it
won't work for these i do want to dress
that though i'm going to try and do a
little macro matter to to transform
these four comps into sort of the lift
ms underneath the hood and sort of come
out that way so that we can have the
same sort of logic by the way if you
don't want to use this library if you're
looking for something to think about in
our comparison there are some things
called mono transformers they will work
with the four comprehensions but i'm
telling you that at my library is faster
and yeah i only went up to three so has
going up to five skull is supposed to go
up to 20
too I wrote the third one of each and
then I said dear lord I need to write
something to write this for me and I
just haven't gotten around to it but i
will i will eventually do that it's
libraries based on scala said so if you
guys are using cats and your code base
and you want to move to that and i'm
putting in something that's slightly
conflicting don't worry i am going to
fix this miles saban actually came out
with a wonderful tool and that's going
to allow me to build that sort of a
swappable back end so that if you want
to use cats or actually prasad you asked
for algebra i don't know if you're still
here but i'm going to do that one first
because it came from in-house but then
cats and that way you can pick and
choose which one you want to bring in
which one you want to import so these
are all the plugins that i'm using for
documentation because documentation
sucks and it's hard and i will tell you
this I've got all these markdown things
using SBT taught which Rob Norris did if
you guys have never used SPD taught you
right mark down and it actually compiles
all your code examples so that you have
to keep honest with these with this
stuff so this will keep pace with a
library and if it doesn't there's
compile error and you know I just am
having the dandus time getting this in
the Jekyll because Jekyll and me is like
for some reason of foreign language so
there's any of you that know Jekyll and
want to help me I would really
appreciate this or if like you want to
get some open source stuff this is a
this is this is it that's your ticket
right in right there and I'd be
eternally grateful I'm at 0.3 so that
should tell you that this is a library
that's still a little experimental you
can take it you can use it I would love
for you to do it I can guarantee you it
will compile because everything is done
at compile time and if it doesn't
you can open up a ticket but I I doubt
you to have problems dunno though if
you're writing your own types and that
sort of thing that because it's based on
scholars eat and it's using scholars it
under the hood there are certain
guidelines for some of this stuff so
lift Matt I need functors lift flatmap I
need functors all the way down to
actually a bind so I don't need a full
monad I just need a bind and things
along those lines so binds just
something with a flat map sort of I'm
wish you wash if there's like deep
theoretical mathematical stuff the codes
over at my github if you guys want to
take a look and that's it